[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs nous allons
accueillir les joueurs pour la deuxième
partie puisque mathieu cornette d'un
estrosi de ses buts et avec el-houari
cours avec des blancs
[Musique]
alors attention
oui les pions de passe est liée sans
l'après fort allez une sicilienne à une
sixième avec des six voilà c'est parti à
la variante que mathieu corne est
pratiqué depuis quelques temps cette
variante avec foulée trois fous ces deux
puits des 4/10 en théorie un peu vite
l'argent qu'on soit prêt oui mais cette
position a été jouée deux fois hier
effectivement donc c'est un début une
sorte de sicilienne lente
oui l'alliance dit bizarre à ses débuts
on met le foulard après on met là et on
diffère le coût des quatre voies la
rencontre ont atterri à jour mais on a
défendu l'intérêt c'est de défendre avec
le pion c3 donc d'avoir les deux pieds
en sang trop puissant et ont défendu
tous fous parce que le cavalier peut pas
défendre en fait on peut pas sortir le
cavalier du coup ici pour défendre en os
4 voilà donc on a on veut imposer de
force entre blancs c'est l'idée de vous
les 3 es fou ces deux sorties moment où
les noirs enjoué le centre retenue
4 voilà alors la question mais le temps
donc évidemment 19 minutes 18 on voit
pas les secondes en fait les secondes
apparaissent quand en dessous de 2
minutes se disent oui au sein de la
ligne de 10 il me semble donc pour celui
distillé toutes les dix secondes et
après on voit les secondes exact que
vers la fin c'est progressif ont un
dernier coup donc alors on va quand même
récapitule le match c'est très important
au nom donc là ah oui là pouvoir a gagné
cornette doit gagner cornet de gagner si
matthew corneille ne gagne pas donc
et bien c'est romain edouard qui sera
déclaré champion vainqueur de ce grand
prix déchets 2007 et qui donc succédera
au palmarès à laurent frayssinet et pas
qu'on va lire court vainqueur l'an
dernier et anatoli karpov champion du
monde le grand grand karpov en 2005 et
aussi sera dans la lignée de alexei
shirov peter l'écho michael adams les
meilleurs joueurs du monde sur ce grand
prix des chèques de bordeaux ce serait
incroyable quand même il ya quand même
du lourd avec hicham abouchi laurent
frayssinet oui oui bien sûr des grands
maîtres de mes forces
et bien en fait non ça sera un de ses
deux petits jeunes là mathieu cornette
ou romain edouard qui vont damer le pion
c'est le cas de le dire
ils vont damer le pion à ces
championnats donc tours 8
mais qu'ils sont jeunes aussi laurence
riffier on peut dire que la veste quatre
ans et il ya un peu plus de six mille
cavaliers leader chez vainqueur du grand
prix il aura 8 ans à l'alluré où ça va
incroyable qu'elle avait 17 a été joué
par romain edouard voilà le problème d
des cavaliers échec dès que des cases ne
sont pas encore offert là ça c'est bien
pour les dieux comparer puis le le pion
aux 5 est toujours toujours pour l'apple
une épine
dans le coeur noir pour favoriser le jeu
d'attaqué et auquel il va certainement
venir sur la case des 5
très certainement voilà exactement des
cinq logique oui mais on voit bien que
ça dégarni un tout petit peu la défense
du roi il ya plus de cavaliers à la
défense du pion h7 donc il peut y avoir
des menaces imaginons par exemple
william dam des trois pour le cavalier
venu ici mais sur dam des trois voiles
après la menace d'un prend 1,7 et
c'était quasiment mat
voilà très souvent le coup et cinq
années intérêt aussi qui est de la
libération de la case de 4 pour le
passage d'un cavalier cavaliers
l'avantagent de m ayew 4 il est double à
la fois en contrôle très bien la case m6
on peut sacrifier éventuellement plus
tard ici on peut venir aussi en d6 et
surtout en libère aussi le fou c'est un
peu en fait sortir ben haj si c'est une
bonne nouvelle
un petit affaiblissement sa mère le roi
très bizarre ce coup c'est une bonne
nouvelle oui pour les joueurs blancs où
il avait peur il avait peu ramé il avait
raison d'un gabarit carrière g5 qu'il
avait raison d'avoir peur oui il voulait
pas d'un quadrillage et singles s'il ya
déjà deux cavaliers qui protège la cage
des cinq et même si affoué dame ici il
ya encore bien sûr ainsi qu'ils
protégeaient cette case il faut savoir
que quelquefois on est obligé de
d'affaiblir sa position pour colmater
colmater les cases pour contrôler la
case du 5ème sommet détendu heureux
noter un peu oui trop mathieu j'aimerais
bien que mathieu égalisé pour 28 gagner
cette partie il se sent donc je suis
très content qu'il ait qu'il amène des
pièces sur les leroy et vers le roi noir
parce que je sais que dès qu'il a tout
forme est une
position active avec quelques pièces
après d'un roi ça sent bon l'attaqué ça
sent bon la tacc il va trouver là oui
oui mais sur va attaquer mais ces
cavaliers projet c'est oui suivi d'un
prend 1,6 peut-être avec un roi
complètement dénudé et suivi de la de
coups de damas où il aime bien avoir les
deux cavaliers dans le voisinage du roi
saddam ans je peux jouer sur notre plan
aussi il peut continuer par quadrillage
de la belgique at-on pu comme dans
l'espagnol oui oui attaquer ici un oui
oui c'était fisher qui avait montré ce
plan là ils jouent et qui a voyagé de
cavaillé j'ai quatre noms d'entraîneurs
manière allégée 4 pour attaquer dès les
cases noires la case h6 en liaison avec
le fou pour faire un sacrifice
ici vous voyez sur cette tâche 6 ou
alors peut-être trop même faire un échec
enrichissent peut-être enfin bon tout ça
il faut peut-être pas s'emballer non
plus parce que si ça marche pas après on
a perdu la partie
il prépare d'abord ils préparent email à
tour en juin et aux grains c'est un
raisin t il avant d'ajouter trois otages
5 bien maîtrisé ce pion qui est quand
même la clé de voûte de la position
blanche alors à noter que maintenant le
coût d'un des trois ne menacent plus
m'attend h7
ah oui il a pris la solution qualiac
puis le cavalier protège là mais c'est
un cavalier défensif en cavalier passif
cinq cavaliers défensif wimille donc
gênant ça défend très bien ouais c'est
pour défendre il faut un
voilà ça défend très bien la balle et on
est cavalier ton général est très
difficile à avoir
sophie l'attaqué contre un cavalier
adams et 4 c'est une une manière
d'amener la dame sur sur la case et g4
évidemment dame g4 vis-à-vis avec le roi
et la menace simplement fou prend pions
parce qu'on peut pas reprendre ensuite
ici puisque la dame g4 fort échec orange
et 8 donc c'est interdit donc dame c4 un
petit passage petits patients
géométriques en passage en force
on ne passe
on va ici on aurait pu devenir l'un mais
il y avait un vis-à-vis avec le fou un
peu embêtant oui donc ambiance et qu'a
donc en rien ces quatre pour allergique
à tout pages a4 ou de toute façon la
dame est pas si mal an j'ai 4 ans et 4
pour l'instant mais c'est évident
l'attaqué non mais là j'ai l'impression
que lui donc c'est au riz la position
noir moi j'aime pas du tout ce genre de
position je sais ça il va falloir
défendre il faut être défense et ça
c'est peut-être la meilleure qualité des
romans edwards être défense et oui c'est
ça le problème
mais ses joueurs d' attaque mais faut
pas oublier que dans la première partie
c'est matthew connaître qui avait pris
l'avantagé ils avaient quand même un
gros pions de plus oui oui mais que ce
n'est pas ce qu'il a oublié le coutour
f6 que les blancs ont pu reprendre
l'avantagé
ouais c'est parce qu'il avait perdu son
sens bélier centrale qui compensait le
dynamisme la paire de fou qu'il avait
perdu cette première partie il est
possible que mathieu joue un peu mieux
positionnés manque aux romains mais
romain aussi très très fort tactiquement
ah oui toujours les ressources on l'a
toujours dit ce grand prix alors mal
mais là je trouve incroyable la matu
avance prudemment donc il à surprotéger
e5 donc il va pouvoir amener sa dame sur
les droits et créer quelques quelques
menaces angers 4 oui j'ai quatre
cavaliers h5 comme g4 il pourra jouer
cavalier h5 pour encore 10 h 5 pour
viser la case de 6 peut-être chasser le
cavalier des cinq par le petit pied en
c4 et puis ensuite avoir les mains
libres pour jouer cavalier abscisse un
jour quand le cavalier seul aux 5
on a peu à regarder ces deux fous comme
ils sont forts ils s'embrassent sur la
caddel si si il se sacrifie c'est
toujours possible
il sent libre et le cavalier peut sauter
en h 50 ils venant mais ces salaires
même
voilà la précaution nouvelles
précautions mais j'aime pas souvent ça
me rappelle christophe car pauvre
kasparov à la c1 à lyon
oui c'est en 1981 j'ai pu bois et la
police s'étaient fait salement mater ces
thèmes 90 il s'était fait mater ici en
jouant ce genre de coup quand on est
attaqué ce genre de coup je ne sais pas
si alors là ça fait peur avec tout ce
qu'il ya sur le roi jouer encore aux
achats suite c'est moi je vais je crois
que je crois que les ans on gagne en moi
c'est pas une connectique 3g bien sûr
manière il ya trop d'attaqués c'est trop
puissant il faut juste pas se tromper
dans leur langue des coups mais je vois
pas comment les noirs peuvent sauver une
position qui a l'air aussi difficile à
défendre
il ya trop de pièces à la taille pour
les blancs voilà que les rails et
cavaliers h5
non mais c'est vrai il va y avoir des
paris qu'il faut plus que je vous dise
si oui je le dis je change donc des
menaces maths et sciences puis surtout
après un sacrifice 1 h 6 en à la belle
case m6 on ne sait pas c'est pas de la
dame qui arrivent là dedans cela fait
toujours qui pourra tourner je vois pas
comment la grille doit voir cela il faut
jouer c'est le cours pour essayer lancé
le coup qu'on n'a jamais envie de jouer
de leur f cell id ça avantage c'est que
ça à la fois ça protège ici et 5 en plus
ça donne un peu d'air parce que la dame
c7 va pouvoir défendre latéralement
oui d'emprise an passé voilà prise en
passant il est voué à l'espion est
faible ce pion fm voilà qu'il a concédés
qui a valu on ferme
cavalli prend les moyens avec tempo sur
la tour mais ça c'est une faiblesse
voilà ça y est j michel bahuaud maths
mais il ya voilà coup de pions près le
puy ans et 5 ça y est gain de pions qui
ont aussi ce faible est en passe de
finir encore davantage blanche oui les
coûts passif des noirs la relation
défensif et passifs en la beauty à la
perte d'un pion alors en tout cas c'est
bien beau spectacle si si matthew bourne
et arrive à gagner cette partie puisque
ça fera égalité et on aura droit à des
blitz de départage quasiment tous les
matches ce grand prix
oui c'est à dire il ya eu que deux
matchs qui se sont des filles décidé à
riom les blitz vent il faut qu'il fasse
un petit peu attention quand même à 100
petits retards de développement à sept
tours à un quine qui ne jouent pas aimé
ce fou sorte quand ils veulent la sas et
ouais il a sauvé la tacc de maths au
prix de 5 ml oui mais un pur ou 5 faible
il est quand même circuit centrale c'est
vrai c'est méchant centrale mais vous
voyez mathieu va jouer quoi là peut-être
juifs ou 4,7 faut quatre cette fois chez
eux qu'à trop changer les pièces
échangées 2 pouces et 6 ont la charge et
les pièces et que tu t'y vas mettre un
cavalier avocate rivages de calvi et des
deux est le cas les noirs restent avec
leurs faiblesses et leurs plus en a
moins bien sûr gros avantage blanc as-tu
corne est en passe de d'égaliser au
score et bien hauteur 1 3 minutes voilà
il saura minutes pour avoir une position
de plus c'est la position supérieure à 3
minutes on voit bien aussi autant l
avantage car primature cornette 6,6 hors
mais doit réfléchir plus c'est bien
qu'il a des soucis c'est un indicatif
oui là je pense que mathieu doit doit
regarder ce qui se passe avec fougue
quatre cavaliers aux 6,1 sur un an ils
vous donnent ces 15 ou d'abord dame c4
mais pourquoi qu'olivier de ce qu'on lit
et de secousses et de passer encore une
fois peut-être un la dame
sur l'aileron en b3 et menacé de mener
huit matches pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
les commandes et mat
bon il suffirait de sortir le cavalier
pour que la tour contrôler la case
ouais mais là ils forcent à six
cavaliers g6 par exemple y aurait des
nefs cette attaque le cavalier et
attaque la dame chance les chargés d'âme
sur quoi après faut prendre f7 ce qui
est à dire oui c'est de gagner d'une
qualité d'avoir gardé le vis-à-vis weeds
en gamme c4 menace a en fait sauvé 3 tu
as raison qui menace
voilà message était en train de
réfléchir à ça oui parce que si la dame
sort du vis-à-vis par exemple de f1 je
sais pas fou prend f3 et ça casse ça
casse la stricte à structure donc il
faut que la dame
voilà voilà bien le g4 elle défend bien
cavaliers et bien elle est vraiment
cavaliers il faut défendre le khalife 3
et pas reprendre évidente du pion qui
gardait la défense la défense du roi il
faut que son attention soit bien défendu
le jeu noir et dynamique là un pont pour
le prix d'un pion il a toutes ces pièces
libre c'est vrai sauf ce cavalier fuite
qui n'est pas exceptionnel mais oui de
jouer au théâtre qu'à qu'à travers le
fonds insisté peut-être appris b4 et
cagoulés du fou fameux et nous avons
alors à 5 b4 même oui il nous a montré
alors là le 4-4 attaque le cavalier
nouvelle cavaliers c'est un autre 1 h 4
ils peuvent aider en d2 aussi attention
à 3,5 et pour attaquer ou quatre oui
c'est pas simple la dame la dame est
exposée maintenant
cette dame voiliers ont foulé la paire
de floup faire de fou peule a travaillé
un peu avec foulée cette foulée points
et 5 de l'activité ces deux fous sont
puissants pourquoi parce qu'il tape sont
des diagonales centrale notamment
oui maintenant ce pion aux captures un
peu le foot c'est de le fou ce n est pas
encore sortie même si t'appelles que sur
1,6 mais ils bouchent la sortie des
tours alain par contre la tour à 8 peut
venir en retrait vis mathieu va
peut-être regarder le ku'damm h5 puisque
six pieds en prime trois on prend la
tour e 8 et on arrivait trop vite non
non non non ont volé quatre sur lille il
ya aussi il ya aussi la prise annales si
ce qui est intéressante ce genre de 25
pour les prises ici oui sur damage 5
on prend peut-être joué faux prince six
là il faut sauver les cavaliers oui mais
si on laisse les cavaliers pros quatre
mois il faut prendre quatre ils étaient
trois fois sur l'a15 oui alors c'était
cool ils étaient trois fois sur la
classe à tour c'est pourquoi il a donné
un pion cette année noire
il est plus un pion près il veut jouer
avec le les pièces les pièces activer le
retard développement tant que la torah
ne joue pas il peut avoir des points de
moins c'est qu'un nature se réveillera
que les pions pèseront lourd
donc finalement et donc il a pris quand
je pensais que ce n'était pas jouable
mais messi messi messi mais alors le
problème c'est que la première rangée
pour l'instant un peu faible parce que
les tours sont pas liés il pourrait y
avoir des combines mais on ne sait pas
s'il a peut-être joué un peu vite on
trouve quatre ans ma gloire alors
ennuyer temps le coup était quand même
il lors duquel il a toujours trois
minutes de retard et puis parler du
matériel elle a trois minutes
le matériel de retard un deuxième pion
ça va commencer à faire beaucoup
nous prendrons tout reprend comme ces
six à pas mal de ces attaques la torah
oui bien sûr si tours contours
évidemment tour 30 tours moi et mon jour
a simplement joué trois ans quelque
chose on s'en prend il simplifie tout
les 4 il va sortir le fola échanges
maintenant tu propose de jouer foudroyé
il faut être à la fois bouché la colonne
de la tour voilà est sûre sur b4 jouera
peut-être sous les 4 et surtout des
quatre ont joué le coup foulée 4 d-4d
4-way possible mais c'est en position
quand ses droits
vraiment on a deux pilotes plus on a
deux qui en plus n'a c'est vrai avantage
blanc toujours les bleus laissent les
pièces noires ne sont pas
particulièrement bien coordonné une
faute soit à cassaigne a pas de
coordination de vrais de vrais
coordination de pièces l'attention sur
montées en trois sets ça va faire
beaucoup beaucoup on peut jouer
peut-être à 5 avec les noix avec idb 4
pouces et d'attaquer cet îlot de pions
une attaque de minorités tour 4
intéressant pose la question l'adav
voilà d'envoi la dame est ce que la d15
la la case g3 la case est roi où la case
h c'est la case g3 est bien parce qu'en
vise b8 irazein mais j'ai trouvé très
bien puisqu'on attaque et bien on ne
craint pas fois le 5 puisqu'il cavaliers
prend donc donc d'alger 3 bis b 8 le
clouage sur la vie normale entre airolo
d'alger 3 vise la case b vite avec
clouage du cavalier sur le roi la dame
attaquant ici cette grande
ranger ranger traverse ranger dans la
nomenclature moderne et traverse dans la
nomenclature ancienne mais c'est la même
chose et voilà dame f5
il préfère avoir saddam saddam libre
mais oui
il y avait 7 4 on n'a pas vu ça oui vous
avez vu j'ai 3 h 5 et on n'avait pas vu
la case à case f5 fait chaud c'est
toujours ce qu'on n'ont pas toujours non
d'accord on trouve des fois on trouve à
4,5 alors savoir qu'elle a le bon goût
le coût normal
ah mais c'est pas mal l'idée c'est que
la tour contrôle des cats et ça s'est
passé de 4,3 alors les blancs peuvent
s'apprendre dommage qu'il n'ait pas joué
d'alger 3 parce que sur dame mais 8i
l'attaqué et le lecavalier f8 et le pied
en mai 4 il avait réalisé qu'elle mail
par le coup b4 bien sûr puisqu'ils
contrôlaient aussi le pion b4 ici mais
il n'a pas joué ce couloir il a joué le
coup de 9 5 qui trouve un peu plus voyez
pas ce qui est je pense qu'il veut
utiliser sa tour sur la colonne d un peu
moins précis vue utilisateur sur la
colonne des pour pour embrouiller taux
d'amh g3 urgent ou de cannes et 17 pour
les noirs oui parce qu'il peut y avoir
un coup comme un tournant il en rit oui
il peut y avoir un coup comme autour des
heures et tour des huit tours des uns ne
craignant pas fou prendre des huit à
cause de dame prend la fuite échec et
d'apprendre des 8 et 2 pièces pour la
tour donc peut-être peut-être amélie à
tour sert aussi pour nous pour ses seins
aussi en plus forte hausse est aussi
puisque tour c'est un pur ces attentats
et attaques la dame sait si c'est la
même si la tour cela la casse et 8 et
protéger un tacle alger par l'adam la 4c
8 et donc le feu alors attention
l'intérêt de ce coup là tombé 4 c'est
que le pion b2 est attaquée et que voilà
voilà ton c'est un marathon c'est alors
il peut peut-être joué tour c4 c'est ce
que j'étais en train de me dire oui mais
après les changes après les chances ça
paraît pas terrible il restera deux
pions de plus ouais mais ce qu'on peut
les garder les pions pour aller rendre
mais encore là il restera au moins 1
puis restera le pion à cette fragile et
chili
chez les noirs et les cases fragile pas
du rebond
c'est bon je me sens qu'il va être
obligé de changer une tour je suis en
train de réfléchir à ça il est ici des
changes la tour parce qu'il a envie
aussi peut-être de jouer cavalier 1 5 1
jour 1 pour forcer les changes du fou
est resté avec dame avec la dame et le
four battu qu'on est en passe de pouvoir
égaliser et siro mais doit égalise
arrive à faire nul si finul eh bien il
remporte le grand prix puisqu'il mène 1
oui mais là bel avantage aux tonnes de
beurre et puis de plus en plus et autant
aussi bien sûr c'est important
et attention car le cavaliere fuite sera
cloué d'autant plus qu'il réfléchit
encore ses droits que ce sera difficile
difficile de défendre le roi noir n'est
pas bien la jouer de f5 parce qu'ils
contrôlent la case h7 du roi
qu'il a vu la faiblesse de la huitième
des biens pour la 6e fois de ce grand
prix très certainement nous aurons droit
encore une fois donc à l'église de
départage si mathieu quand on est arrivé
à confirmer cet avantage important sur
l'échiquier
donc on verra des blitz dantès finale
aussi ça sera la sixième fois je crois
même que deux autres mathieu va sans
doute échanges et la dame puis et puis
essayer de gagner sa finale il a le
temps il a de plus en plus il ya pas de
raison qu'ils se fassent bricoler qui va
changer les dames oui je pense qu'il va
charger les dames et jouer b3 et puis
jouer il va s'en occuper un pion mais
quelqu'un comment je sais pas
après b3 les pieds en sang sur blanc
est-ce qu'il peut la sauver
li va sans doute échangé le fou le cadre
noir alors jouer autour des 1 il ya les
deux colonnes et puis fait 4 il peut y
réfléchit sans doute j'étais en train de
me dire
renault ou simple coup d'essai c'est
quand ils échangent et d'amérique avec
le matériel de plus c'est le temps de
l'avancé au kia il va pas perdre c'était
plus dur contrôle si ses meilleures
chances sont dans la finale avec de plus
en plus quand même trois contre deux ici
dix minutes contre 7 minutes 20 donc
avantage clair net puissant pour mathieu
corner dans la b3 mais c'est pas gagné
c'est pas gagné parce qu'on peut faire
nous échec il ya beaucoup de
possibilités de faire nul alors là il va
déjà jouer torres 6 voilà donc on sait
assez derrière le pion voilà déjà la
menace évidemment des blancs c'est
pourtant cavaliers ou valve cavaliers et
il n'y a pas beaucoup cas ce cavalier
dominé par le fouet
il domine et on va voir que ces cases
ici ici ici et ici sont dominés par là
le four et sur la case focal c'est à
dire le world trade et de liant leur
nier les deux lignes il lorgne les deux
lignes alors des dominés donc il faut
des reculs est rien c'est pas beau hein
c'est une des forces du fou par rapport
aux cavaliers c'est de pouvoir contrôler
le cavalier ici peut se placer sur la
case faut qu'à la case et de rencontre
des deux lignes de contrôle quand ici la
case de trois ce serait une grosse
erreur je pense que jouer ça puisque
voilà j'aime pas du tout ce qu'on voit
là doctorat 6 en août
voilà 6 voilà derrière le piano bien vu
au lac aller bessette et passifs un
cavalier baisse est peut-être mais il
défend oui peut-être fou b6 maintenant
non oui pourquoi pas millions 2,6
attention combine est impossible aussi
gros avantage blanc un sénateur voit
bien ses deux pions contrôle ici trois
pions contre de le trouver
y'a pas de problème fou cavaliers contre
vous travaillez en plus c'est des fous
de même coup leur rôle à la tour
idéalement placé derrière le pion
lavables la foule olala aux violences a
fait la saf en troisième ronde un
troisième pion nous quitte
ouhlala oui alors l'idée c'est que tout
simplement s'ils ont bien sûr et il n'a
pas oublié et on récupère l'eau qui il a
pas oublié la tactique c'est au prince
six tiens qui traînait et en gagnant en
troisième mais c'est peut-être le moment
de jouer à 4 1 à 4 il y aura foule des
deux on reviendra ici avec nous pour
attaquer la tour alors il a peut-être
calculé foulée de apprend b3 et sur flu
protour b2 et le pion glonass dame le
pion fait dame le pion fedama tension
oui parce que lecavalier ne reviennent
pas la case des deux étangs sur les
parlers on prend il y aurait comme les
c5 donc fou des deux fait quand même
est ce qu il ferait jouer ce qui s'y
passait il n'a pas vu il ya peu vu
qu'ils en profiteront si si mais surpris
on prendrait tout il jouera tout
simplement apprendre mais trois oui
environ environ
il reste avec deux pions de plus en plus
oui mais du même côté du même côté mais
c'est c2c a gagné depuis un an de plus
et il n'a pas vu ça mathieu s'est
d'ailleurs il a joué la variante prend
quand même le cavaliere parce que le fou
les pentes des deux allait oui oui c'est
mon accord cavalier b un ça va c'est
fini voilà ça va arriver ça va et oui en
prenant la tour il libère la case aux
cavaliers donc la variante été trouvé la
variante été trouvé edwards a eu la même
illusion que moi le fou en d2 ne restez
pas en d2 il prônait la tour b 4e tour
dans la case pour cavaliers bien sûr
bien sûr donc là et bien donc égalité
eh bien on va avoir droit va avoir droit
aux épices de départage le match cornet
à égaliser nous allons avoir droit des
pistes de départage le temps de ranger
le matériel donc mathieu cornette
devrait avoir l'hymne l'europe
[Musique]
incroyable ce grand prix est totalement
incroyable on n'aura pas plus de cinq
minutes pour souffler quand même
extraordinaire donc le matériel a des
vertus alors attention sur moi à 100 dès
qu'on sera prêt quand même ça va pas me
faire le coup à chaque fois alors donc
c'est cornette et de voir voilà donc ça
va être cinq minutes par joueur
ça va partir pan du voile assez répandu
se rafraîchit tout de suite envoyé cinq
minutes par joueur
voilà donc c'est parti la variante rosso
limogé cas sicilienne 3 donc c'est une
autre variante assez quand même oui
mathieu va prendre oui non mais mathieu
cornette il revient de loin tous ses
matches dans tous ses matches il a il
est revenu à olivier rhône et le bon
joueur est toujours chance il est revenu
face à laurent frayssinet et là il vient
de revenir face à romain edouard donc
histoire se répète
est-ce qu'il va terminer le grand prix
en ayant gagné tous ses matches en
revenant du diable vauvert diable
vauvert et bien ça en prend le chemin
notre ami zitrone à dessein que ça leur
pas malsain
oui là je pense qu'il est dans dans une
préparation
là nous sommes dans une préparation
parce que je sais que c'est bien connais
bien la re so lu ment ça va être un bon
coup là et c'est sans doute pas prendre
en dessin puis si la dame du faire un
travail à la maison ça ouvrir et les
lignes si haut si on fait plus on prend
des cinq puis on prend ça ouvre la
colonne pour la tour l'a bien sûr mais
ça c'est pas bon et en cours le roi au
centre donc il faut pas prendre un sens
et on aura gagné une majorité allèles
dame il faut sans doute rappeler jouer
les jolis coups les 5
c'est terrible il faut peut-être joué à
y prend quand même prise prise voilà et
belle majorité ll dames deux contre un
alors ici une petite marge brute t2
contre 1 oui et majorité noire au centre
alors attention quand même parce que rob
edwards est énorme en mythe on l'a vu
aussi depuis le début de ce grand prix
donc un partout oui mais s'ils arrivent
à voilà il prend f3 voilà ça c'est ça
s'avère essentielle c'est une très bonne
nouvelle sa réelle à la prise en f3 que
qu'il n'est plus cette paire de fou
qu'un joueur d'attaqué qui est privé de
sa paire de fou c'est déjà moins bons
joueurs tu crois par voyager
reparti je prends le parti pour mathieu
donc là le mauvais foulée noir 5 avec
pour cibles où j'ai évidemment il bouche
ici l'oeil
il bouge pour là pour contrôler at
contre la tour est évidemment il a évité
la prison le 6 qui était une très
mauvaise nouvelle et donc il faut que
les normes et n'invite joue très vite
sans doute vous aux 7es petit rock mais
les blancs brossé de l'empêcher sans
doute un oui puis le cavalier s'être c3
sera très puissant c'est trop mal 7
mais bon c'est du blitz et à trois
minutes quarante trois minutes quarante
attention il faut savoir changer de
rythme parce que c'est plus dur et plus
de semi rapide allaient devoir joue très
vite il faut se mettre en mode blitz
romain edouard joue très vite inhumain
de très bons très bons beats on l'a vu
comment il a réussi rare il a fait
tomber autant douchy oui oui toujours
aux aguets voilà ça c'est quand même
bien joué de changer l'âme la mauvaise
laisser au noir leur mauvaise pièce le
vernis pourquoi c'est le mauvais parce
qu'il est sur la même couleur que ses
pions que ses pions donc voilà j'ai
quatre pour assurer pour empêcher la
classe de quatre cavaliers ont pris chez
f5 et peut-être il peut faire peut-être
cavaliers g3 donc traite un lien très
bien aux échecs ce qui est important
c'est pas les pièces qui sont échangés
c'est ce qui reste sur l'échiquier sais
pas ce qui sort de l'échiquier c'est ce
qui reste est donc là il reste un
mauvais fou il bourse cavaliers
lecavalier quand on le mange bien on
peut dire que les vrais majorité ll dame
voilà les blancs ont l'avantagé de bons
vieux depuis un contrôle l'autre côté le
cavalier supérieur au fond pourquoi
parce que bien se fout et contre bute
contre ses propres pions donc il
n'attaque pas le camp ennemi là pas
question de laisser la colonne s'est il
faut s'y opposer il est défensif alors
que
tours s'est mis en tête aux pacéens
suisse d'un v6 pour attaquer bedo il va
attaquer les pieds en sommes à ces
achats possibles
la double attaque double attaque
il n'a pas dû voir sa matu cornette
il peut jouer encore dame b3 qui défend
un qui défend les deux puis surtout les
3 hommes et 3 c'est pas si fin il y aura
tour b8 produire aux alentours des 8 qui
va simplement attaqué la dame mais il ne
pourra pas tout protéger
ça va être difficile de tout protéger
donc il semblerait qu'il gagne un pion
aux mains edwards et même s'il est noir
récupèrent le pion des six est une bonne
nouvelle pour les cils et blanc récupère
bien et si c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
les noirs d'échangés le pion des 5
contre le clan des six parce que ça va
libérer la libérer le four donc ils
peuvent même prendre ce pion des cinq
sans craindre de perdre le clan des six
derrière arriérés à laquelle j'ai 3
voilà ça c'est le problème par contre
puisque qualif 5 menace j'ai cinq
voiliers attaque la tour et gagner là qu
il gagne à la colonne ou semblerait que
la les noirs prennent l'initiative
à noter l'impression qu'après tout
reprendre ses visites en france et 8,1
dame f53 y aura eu des cinq caisses qui
avait surtout profité aux france élite
dames f5 qui avait pas une fourchette
qui l'a pas vu effectivement c'était une
fourchette annoncée oui mais il y avait
la tour e et avez la tour père d'eilat
où il y avait la tour 1 les voilà ce
qu'il y avait voilà ce qu'il y avait là
tu perdais l'avant bon hockey lac
simplement d'accord il prend même pas le
pion évidemment mais voilà bien il était
hâtive est beaucoup plus forte
l'activité il vient ici
ah là là où
attention petit oeil sur la kf2 et
défense latérale du pur des six attaques
et par le cavalier ce qu'il veut c'est
s'est améliorée s'en fout je ne sais pas
le client qui voulait s'était amélioré
le font certainement il va réactiver
s'en fout assas et puis ses intentions
oui oui menace attention très fort si le
fou arrive assez réactive et sur b 6
il devient énorme plus pareil à 7 g 1
c'est plus pareil parce qu'il va
attaquer sur f2 ça va être extrêmement
puissant alors peut-être que les noirs
peuvent jouer d'un prend b2 avec l'idée
foulée 6 attention quand même à la
tacticien h 5 h 6 avec menace de maths
on n'y croit pas trop
on n'y croit pas mais bon bon il vient
ici pour pour venir en g4 évidemment et
pour aller à 9,6 avec le cavaly venir
henri iv est en effet si sur un petit
échec et essayer de maths est regardé
comme ses pions contrôler les casses
faible il ya plus plongé cette pour
protéger les cases noires f5 tri sayedi
gcc pour ne pas subir le bien joué cinq
bien sûr allait revenir sesat 1
finalement oui oui oui il a laissé
tomber cette pseudo pression ici et il
n'a pas pris des pions non non non ils
sont pas fous ses joueurs f5 alors il
doit se poser la question s'il prend pas
j'ai l'impression
belles cases voilà une belle case pour
le cavalier way sur carte blanche c'est
vrai mais la câble et mes belles cases
j'aime beaucoup qui attaquent des six ça
c'est des pions d'attaquants qui
attaquent des six
oui mais là ça le cavalier qu'on pense à
partir du moment où le le bélier a admis
le bélier resta en vie locale laquelle
le cavalier c4 est stable le belly c'est
ça oui c'est ça et le cavalier c4 est
stable c'est-à-dire un bélier contre on
vieillit oui bordeaux contre cornes et
le fou d'exception le le fou est
malheureux là il faut toujours défendre
des six mois la faute défendre ce pion
lecavalier bien passé f4 c'est pour
ouvrir la colonne le cadre bien sûr pour
faire la colonne bon mais ouais je sais
pas si le foot oui il joue le toujours
le thème contre le fou le cavaliere
voilà c'est hélas mal venu à cannes elle
veut jouer à quatre il veut affaiblir le
pion b3 qui protège le cavalier et
ensuite il veut attaquer plombier 3
attention loyal ou le coup h5 avec
l'idée de venir h5 travailler sur la
colonne achats mais là ils vont changer
d'âme oui la seule colonne ouverte c'est
la colonne en écharpe c'est la colonne
âge qui sera la seule colonne ouvert
comprend et il sera en mesure touche de
l'occuper il sera en mesure d'occuper la
colonne h le premier gala mais où il
compte s et la conteste bien sûr tour en
reprend tour échec non de loyer les
charges et damman un point d'accord le
foot en 2010 par le fou est dominé par
le cavalier voilà travailler plus fort
le cavalier oui 47 secondes 46 attention
ça va se jouer autant maintenant il a ça
va aller très attention c'est même plus
une question dont il peut se passer
n'importe quoi a très vite
attention il peut aussi que des pièces
disparaissent de l'échiquier si les
joueurs ça y est il va il va lui appuyé
au sol
puis on prend j'en prends olala ou 3 3
mais il le contrôle avait le cavalier
oui mais alors ça devient passif mais
quatre pas mal bien joué oui oui oui oui
j'ai joué ici on est comme frôlé le pire
est sous contrôle les fous et passifs
le bio est sous contrôle et filmé au tac
ça y est le pire et le pion but va faire
la différence mais oui mais en même
temps ces deux c'est le temps là c'est
l'histoire de fernand raynaud qui sait
c'est le pion b qui sait cette couche
qui sait il yzfr6 convié le plombier
afin de dénombrer lombez le plombier oui
bien sûr oui ça va jouer autant mais dix
secondes contrôle à 11 secondes pour
romain coharde en gros mathieu koné
devrait gagner ce beat on va les prendre
l'aventage danser départager où il reste
que huit secondes à romain rail et le
fluvial looking to est mort et la
position archi peut alors si foutu ap
l'état c'est chiant à rien et puis ça y
est bravo et on a bien fait d'étudier
que lecavalier quelquefois été plus fort
que le move est fou mais mathieu c'est
un gel démonstration est bien autre
incroyable que ça puisse paraître il me
semble bien qu'il n'ya pas ya pattes
mais oui c'est ce qui se passe alors à
huy il n'aurait pas y'a pas tu as oui on
n'a pas vu ça nous donc la partie du lot
les pyrénées ont été nommés croyable
mais oui le roi ne peut plus bouger on
va on va quand même expliqué on croyait
qu'il avait gagné le roi ici les 2,15
lalalalala l'avait alors ces eaux là là
on la fait pas peur
c'est incroyable incroyable s'est passé
ont pensé que c'était fini en avril à la
position finale g on ne peut pas jouer
c'est extraordinaire extraordinaire le
résultat la partie alors qu'il avait 17
secondes contre 4 olalalala l'avait quel
retournement de situation
quel miracle quel miracle hier autour de
vent de situation ah oui mais je n'ai
pas prise et qui avait eu un pacte
tellement la position était fini pour
moi
oh là là là là là on l'avait même pas vu
ronnie wood croyais que j'étais perdu
voilà c'est le comme quoi hier c'est lui
qui place ses ex tandis qu'olivier rhône
et aujourd'hui ce le fait placer
extraits vous voyez que les échecs
extraordinaire donc capa échec et on
peut pas bouger ses pattes
incroyable voyez que même à ce niveau là
on peut rater des trucs comme ça là
c'est dommage parce que la position
était gagné les échecs c'est vraiment
extra la position était gagnant alors
c'est parti donc maintenant à égalité
totale ce qui permet à romain edouard ii
attention de ne pas forcément var et
pour le gain à tous crins oui à une
pierre qui tient une pire qu une défense
pire qu aux films caractérisés par avec
la variante la variante autrichienne le
coude et si c'est le fou en g7 ici oui
on consolide le pion central
ah oui mais lecavalier n'est pas ces
trois thèmes que je pense qu'à gagner
les bleus oui oui non ne servait pas
parce que des fois ça va tellement vite
sur le julier savoir quelle est la
position exacte exact c'est ce qui s'est
passé ça va bouger c'est un débat ok
alors là les blancs mathieu
edward thomas edward les blancs
c'est la première fois que dans ce grand
prix mais il se passe des trucs dingues
cette année sur ce grand prix oui mais
c'est pas gagné cette partie gagnée a
gagné le grand prix il n'y a pas une
conjonction jupiter c'est quoi ce serait
prévue sur bordeaux la voix et le corps
jonction puis on prend qui comprend oui
bien sûr des cinq et il se crée un gros
pion central un puissant puisqu'il va
jouer ces quatre derrière sans doute
avec l'idée sans doute de jouer donc ces
quatre avec un plan c 5 a tout
simplement et plus tard il y aura un
tueur pas céder 6 ou mauvaise nouvelle
le couple cavalier 8
il a raté son début j'ai l'impression
mathieu quand on atteint voyez quand on
est obligé de jouer des coups comme
cavalier b8 d'un échec à la tension un
coup comme dame 17 sur une grosse grosse
faute à cause de foot b5 courage avec
quand même un gros souci est que font
les noirs pas facile qui a veillé des
séries 2 17
voilà mais les blancs ont l'air très
bien dans cette partie oui oui à la
majorité
mobile alors celui qui gagne cette
partie gagné le grand prix de bordeaux
avec lesquels on aura un dernier blitz
oh la la il prendrait après pions sans
travailler problème un bien fou le fou
qui sautent à la problème pour les
pièces noires
faire prendre le cavalier parce que n
accordons bien joué de la part de
mathieu corner puisqu'il va prendre la
case no sign quand même il va avoir la
cades est comme ça c'est intéressant
même s'il a perdu le pion central il a
quand même une belle case ici à la
limite le curieux 4 pas mal ça alors la
menace sans doute trou 5 et d'apprendre
louette l'affaiblissement des voeux que
le roi cela existe toujours le maté
fortiori fou prend le fameux matin
imaginons que l'une des rares ajoute
deux fois de suite faut 5 ensuite fou
prend h2 échec au roi à chiens et forcé
puisque la dame contrôle la kz2 donc il
faut rejouer le roi ici et ensuite vient
le fou vient en g3 pour fermer le
cercueil ici échec de la dame et après
roigé un match de l'adama je deviens
fermathe c'est une combinaison on va
dire classique 1 renault que tu
arriveras tat élèves dans les écoles
oui oui tout à fait donc là il joue au
foot 5 et bien sûr si relief trois pour
défendre
ah oui d'accord si on prend le cavalier
qui défend ils vont prendre réduction il
faut prendre du plomb parce qu'on
n'entend pas subir le madame ces deux
protège il faut plaindre les pions en
attendant le cavalier menace la dame et
le faut cinq dons qu'ils vont être
obligés de prendre 3 il faut prendre
lève toi mais ça a pas l'air très bon
parce qu'on pourra pas empêcher le cadre
au coup suivant et le fou au sein des
dominés avantage blanc oui jeunes
avantage blanc en est incroyable c'est
incroyable
cet article c'est la voirie sur olten à
la carte il a joué les coups trop rapide
extra ou blier oubliant le pas-de-calais
les verts sont la supra et forcé puis on
prend aussi l' inverse que lui a planté
puis l'a planté face à olivier rhône et
oui mais un peu les moeurs
oui l'arroseur arrosé oui il faut il
faut jouer des coups comme g5 maintenant
bon pour garder le faut j'essaye pour
empêcher voyez pour empêcher ce que pour
garder fous vivants voyez pour garder le
fouillis non mais ça affaiblit le rendra
mais oui mais on a déjà un pied en 2 -
une position délicate il faut fouiller
4f clac la même idée
qui n'est pas faux pas là il prend les
cases noires bien sûr il joue très très
bien ce roumain edward et peut jouer ce
cap maintenant à il va revenir mais
lecavalier
il va lui refaire un cavalier contre un
défaut pour l'instant non mais c'est pas
un mauvais fond parce que les pions
soyez pions sur mobile les pièces
mobiles
alors il peut jouer f4 parce qu'il n'a
pas peur de cavaillé g4 puisque dans ce
cas là il y aurait d'alger 3 quasiment
force en échange des dames avec une
signature il faudrait qu'ils cherchent
dès l'ouverture un mathieu cornette a
raté quelque chose dans la foulée vous
sauver la partie où il veut sauver la
partie dans la finale essayer de faire
une nulle avaient les pièces lourdes
voyez finale de centralisation et
s'orienter vers une finale deux tours et
l'annuler en jouant mais il faut qu'ils
jouent vite est là il a dû rentrer crois
pas je crois pas renoncé très fort quand
même il a dit aux gars et 5 à oui oui
bien sûr les quatre maintenant 1,5
voilà ça y est c'est en avant voilà il
défend tout c'est trop fort regarder
travailler les week-ends il a un énorme
centre l'écrasement a les larmes centre
avec un petit plus on peut oui on
appelle ça un écrasement aux échecs 1
c'est vrai se dit oui oui il a peut-être
joué à quatre oui sans doute il veut
jouer à 4 à 4 baies 3 il va consolider
sa chaîne de pions menace des noirs ces
jouets vaisselle sa menace de l'histoire
c'est de faire réfléchir les blancs pour
lui pour qu'il revienne au temps ça y
est le cas car le pire devrait être
passé difficile c'est fini c'est très
puissant et bien romain edouard est en
passe de gagner subite c'est de devenir
le champion le vainqueur de ce grand
prix des chiffres 2007 attention mais on
a vu qu'il peut y aura des retours non
il peut y avoir une pâte encore oui il
peut y avoir
puis lors des six menace pions frantour
et puis on prend un tour on n'a pas peur
au tour prend dame parce qu on referait
dames derrière grossistes voilà là mais
qu'est ce qui se passe les 5 est pas
possible
oh non oui oui dame g3 la g3 ça y est il
faut changer d'âme sinon on perd le
purger 5
et c'est encore plus grave c'est encore
plus grave
et si on change les dames c'est déjà
très grave ces deux structures qu'on me
dit trahi et comme c'est trop fort ça y
est je crois peut-être f6 voilà il le
fait c'est pour alors qu'est ce qui se
passe est désolidarisée les banques
il va jouer roi f2 pas peut-être passé
pas si bien que ça on va il faut
réfléchir l'as pas évident quand même un
endroit j'ai deux voies larges et ils
essaient de voir venir e4 maintenant il
faut jouer très vite il va protéger avec
tout cas oui mais il reste 50 jouet
troyer en plus il est mal autant il faut
jouer très vite
peu importe il faut jouer très vite moi
j'ai pour essayer d'annuler cette finale
deux tours 4 semble évident faut casser
les pieds en si on peut alors 4 est
évident voilà il le fait pour empêcher
au f5
ouais et ils menacent tous riches
cheikhs qui va éloigner le roi sans
doute ils menacent aussi roi des cinq
rois des scènes bien sûr voilà c c'est
trop facile à jouer maintenant qu'on
protège tous voilà on va prendre la
colonne c'est ce sont les blancs qui
vont prendre la colonne c mais oui bien
sûr ça y est les noirs on peut aussi les
noirs jouent ça évidemment il ya 17
c'est terminé voilà ça y est c'est fini
rail va encore non mais c'est fini il va
encore cloué le pion avec tour cédé 8,1
mais l'échec car ils sont livrés un
superbe
ainsi s'ils jouent d'abord c'est fini
voilà abandon c'est fini
c'est fini le la jeunesse sont allés
gagner à roubaix devant les échecs
moderne félix de départage premier ayant
donné lieu à un nul c'est donc romain
edouard qui remporte le prix merci voilà
donc effectivement belle victoire de
romain d'or belle victoire de la
jeunesse une très belle aussi très belle
finale de mathieu connaître peut-être
bien odeurs d'abord aux vaincus avant de
faire parler le vainqueur peut-être
mathieu dans le match c'est un peu
dommage que la première partie j'étais
beaucoup mieux et noir
la troisième j'étais complètement
gagnant je me prends un pacte de reste
quatre secondes histoire de crise les
banques en pleine face aux autres partis
à vélo
ça leur fait un problème c'est normal
qu'on perde à la fin notamment partie la
jungle airplay on peut applaudir et à
l'orgue acteurs robin un petit mot un
petit mot sur cette belle victoire avant
la remise des prix qu'on va faire ça
suffira heureux quand même c'est une
très belle victoire quand même ce grand
prix c'est était loin d'imaginer pouvoir
gagner cet événement beaux vainqueurs
modeste peut l'applaudir encore aussi un
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc que romain edouard 16 ans
champion d'europe et vainqueur de ce
grand prix des chèques de bordeaux alors
je vais je vais appeler est ce que je me
donnais un programme s'il te plaît
patrick je vais appeler laurent
frayssinet qui va rejoindre au 6e rang
fasciné 3e 3e de ce grand prix des
chèques
voilà laurent frayssinet
pour compléter le podium de ce grand
prix voilà mettez vous mettez vous l'a
peut-être on va peut-être à côté de
romain on va remettre le trophée du
conseil général cet opus julien si tu
peux leur maître remet alors voilà je
voulais savoir qu'a tenu toute
l'informatique de ce grand prix vous
pouvez applaudir
voilà alors je vais demander aussi je
crois qu'il ya des partenaires du grand
prix qui sont venus qui sont venus ici
qui sont présents s'ils peuvent venir
sur la scène pour qu'on prenne les
photos merci de venir sur scène voilà je
veux le remercier
pendant que pendant ces personnes
viennent je voudrais remercier le
conseil le conseil général évidemment
qui a hacké soutenu cet avion qui le
soutiennent depuis depuis longtemps je
vous remercie aussi le conseil le
conseil régional qui nous a permis aussi
de résister valency tous les partenaires
privés ils sont nombreux
maintenant ici quelques-uns qui
représentent les différentes sociétés
privées qui vont soutenu cet événement
vous pouvez remercier les dames coeur
voilà on va aussi prendre prendre des
photos qu'est ce que je veux dire oui
alors il ya beaucoup de gens qu'il faut
remercier parce qu'il ya beaucoup
imaginé pour un événement pareil à
beaucoup de gens qui ont travaillé
dessus alors il ya renault évidemment
lagune qui étaient aux commentaires qui
a beaucoup soutenu le grand prix
toute l'année on a pu faire tout un tas
de notamment de réunion et de
communication autour de son club le 36
rue buhan je vous rappelle que demain
les championnats d'aquitaine de parties
rapides 36 rue burrard à bordeaux à côté
du lycée montaigne
c'est ce qui est bordelais à françois
merlet du comité départemental d'échecs
de gironde pour remercier la ligue
d'aquitaine aussi qui a soutenu
l'événement
il ya aussi ri que et je lui sers masse
du camping la rochette qui
malheureusement pas pu venir mais qu'ils
ont aussi soutenu le soutenu le grand
prix je vais en oublier évidemment je
peux pas citer tout le monde parce que
j'ai oublié je vous remercie ma petite
marie aussi qui venus m'aider
ainsi que séverine bennama évidemment
qui est là haut avec séverine aussi dos
santos qui ont fait toute la régie de
diagonale tv qui ont enregistré cet
événement et qui sera disponible aussi
sur internet vous pourrez revoir les
parties en vidéo sur internet quand
elles se rendent line probablement d'ici
la fin du mois de mai voilà vous
remercie tous je sais pas s'il ya des
photos qui sont prises il ya des
photographes qui sont là je sais pas si
c'est en eau pour les photos séverine
voilà de ces bornes c'est bon d'accord
c'est vrai que c'est bon tu après les
photos ok très bien voilà bon écoutez je
vous remercie
je crois qu'on va arrêter là puis après
pour vous laisser envahir la scène aussi
pour faire signer peut-être les
programmes au champion pour les
applaudir une dernière fois
voilà merci à tous et puis à la
prochaine fois pour prochain grand prix
et brand ou encore love and war merci au
revoir
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]